[Aplausos]
de lucro
quem é que sabe o que é de lucro
infecção causada no couro cabeludo por
pelos que se dividem o mesmo calor água
nascer do sol ponto que marca
encruzilhada uma obra literária está nos
grandes jogos da minha infância minha
juventude chamado dicionário também ele
foi chamado tinha esse nome justamente
porque a gente procurava o funcionário
palavras com significados difíceis para
tentar criar um significado pra quem
enganar os outros vão conseguir ganhar o
voto das pessoas como significado
correto
qual seria a definição que você criaria
a de lucro pra poder fazer com que os
outros também votassem você como se
fosse hoje
as duas mesas de madeira as cadeiras de
metal as minhas tias meus tios meus pais
meus primos
meu primo chegando minha tia porque ele
tinha jogo ela tinha jogado uma
lavadeira que tinha acabado com o jogo
de buraco dele cena tradicional da noite
lembro também do quarto da casa da minha
avó onde os primos todos centavo pra ter
uma adrenalina de seu não ser o último a
baixar as capas porque quem baixar ou
por último
tomava uma folha queimada na cara
inevitavelmente o jogo acaba descambava
na risada quando a gente olhava para as
casas dos outros a gente sair daquela
sala a cara toda tomada por fuligem para
desespero dos meus pais
a propósito pra quem achou que dê lucro
bebê nascer do sol
acertou quem não gosto de jogar mesmo
jogar sempre bom
levanta a mão aqui alguém que j todo
mundo que joga
levanta a mão
levanta também a mão você que jovem big
bands e que ele creche porque isso
também é jogo
vamos lembrar então só tem um porém
esse é o lado negro dos jogos
aos poucos depois dessa infância
incrível é que comecei a mergulhar cada
vez mais nos jogos digitais cada vez
mais aquilo foi tomando o meu tempo
retomando minha vida começou a gastar
cada vez mais tempo no mesmo dia a dia
mas o que eu gostaria mas isso seria
saudável
foi então quando há quatro anos depois
de dar carona para mãe que não via há
muito tempo alemão
ele me deu carona e falou que não quer
vir aqui em casa jogar os jogos no
tabuleiro modernas
nunca tive que falar era um universo
completamente desconhecido para mim
foi então quando uma partida de
carcassonne o jogo é baseado
completamente nossas construção de uma
cidade medieval da frança que é toda
murada
já tive meu primeiro impacto forte
intenso arrebatador sentar naquela mesa
é comecei a pensar nas minhas
possibilidades e as possibilidades são
tão e não inúmeras
quanto à história para se contar dentro
do jogo de tabuleiro moderno você pode
experimentar os dilemas de ser um
fazendeiro tentando sobreviver na idade
média
ou então enfrentar os desafios de ser um
escalador está tentando chegar no cume
do everest ou então se a próxima grande
bactéria que vai se transformar numa
pandemia vai acabar com a população
mundial
e aí eu comecei a fazer uma pesquisa
comecei atrás e aí eu comecei a ver que
todos os grandes teóricos da educação a
gente encontrava o valor do brincar de
como as pessoas aprenderam brincar
hoje mesmo se estiver numa inúmeros
exemplos de como brincar é importante
aprendizado 3
só que a pergunta que eu faço é atrair
brincar está falando de jogar
essa linha de segunda grande descoberta
só em português brincar e jogar
são palavras distintas brincar é coisa
de criança jogar é coisa de adulto
só que o player inglês joelho em francês
fillon em alemão e até mesmo as o bo e
japonês
a todos esses idiomas brincar e jogar
são a mesma palavra brincar e jogar são
a mesma coisa a gente tem registro de
jogos na história tão antigos quanto se
tem gente de idéias de registro escrito
em jogos tão antigos quanto no 3 mil 500
antes de cristo entre os egípcios ou
então quando há cinco anos descobriram
um jogo no meio da mesopotâmia tem cinco
mil anos de idade além de ter criado a
escrita
eles também criaram um jogo aqui e ali
animais dotados de inteligência brinca o
tempo todo durante a sua infância cofins
chimpanzés cães gatos e inclusive
algumas espécies
talvez seja por isso que algumas
oficinas que a gente dá nos testes
parecem pais que estão jogando
animadamente entre si nunca se viram
antes depois que seus filhos já se
entediado para fazer outras coisas
talvez nem uma cena assim que damon
tenha dito o ato tudo brinca com a
criança na verdade está brincando
consigo mesmo
meu filho antes mesmo de começar a andar
já tinha seus jogos comigo eu me
escondia e aparecia escondia e aparecer
e ele tinha que adivinhar declarado que
aparecer e ele sempre acertava atribuiu
a isso a sua incrível inteligência
tá bom vai talvez tenha a ver com o fato
de ser pai dele
alguns de vocês também vão se lembrar de
entrar no túnel que não poderia ir até
chegar no final do túnel
na descida de santos
cada túnel que eu achei que enfrentava
era um desafio a ser vencido fica roxa
no final mero detalhe era tão legal que
quando a gente chegava no final a gente
falava possa voltar outros vocês vão se
lembrar de andar na rua e não poder
nunca pisaram à risca
nunca ninguém fez né eu lembro vivamente
pizzas em uma risca o homem das
afiliadas subiriam o seria ferido
mortalmente eu chegaria cambaleando do
outro lado para a criança brincar é algo
muito sério para quem jogava stop cor
com a letra g
[Música]
quem aqui acha que gemma no valo levanta
a mão quem é que acha que genaro vale
vocês podiam ter usado grená em vez de
gelo tá
outra coisa que é muito interessante é
uma regra não escrita do jogo
daquela vez que você se arrependeu da
jogada que você fez e começava
inevitável independentes qual frase a
faltar no jogo voltar quase um tabu
um jogo não se volta uma vez jogado já
foi a vez do outro tipo que nem a vida à
grande compensação disso é que o erro
faz parte do processo o erro é visto
como parte do aprendizado ea partir
disso ele vira uma referência uma
referência muito forte que é uma prova
de como essas coisas ficam na nossa
memória 7 a 1 lembrou a jogar eu aprenda
a fazer escolhas
aprenda ver as consequências meus atos e
aprendendo tudo isso dentro do ambiente
seguro se eu errar eu posso tentar
novamente o jogo que uma outra regra não
escrita
lembra aquela partida de agora o banco
ampliar você tava jogando alguém chegou
e falou assim que ela tinha
quer dizer preso àquela partida
interminável era obrigado a dar o melhor
de mim para transformar aquela
experiência na melhor experiência
possível dependia só de mim
a perseverança aprendida na marra outra
carga de jogos muito muito comum em
jogos festivos nos jogos festivos muitas
vezes objetivo se torna o secundário
quando tem uma boa risada vista o jogo
de funcionário é um ótimo exemplo muitas
vezes é esquecida objetivo que era
ganhar pontos e volta os meus colegas
pra poder simplesmente colocar uma
definição engraçada e aí que os jogos de
tabuleiro mostra sua maior
característica a conexão entre as
pessoas
talvez por isso ana mandou danilo veio
falar comigo uma vez falar assim
obrigado porque agora o meu filho ele
está chamando os amigos em casa ao invés
de ficar o dia inteiro jogando no xbox
outro traço de jogos também chamados
jogos cooperativos os jogos cooperativos
outro no gato no teste
não existe meio termo o que é incrível é
que se a comunicação trabalho de equipe
tudo isso é trabalhar de uma maneira
extremamente viva nas oficinas que a
gente faz jogos cooperativos que leva em
escolas empresas e as pessoas perdem
porque não trabalhar em equipe ea
mensagem que fica é muito clara
se você não jogar em equipes você não
trabalha em equipe
você não vai ganhar a jogar e aprender
humildade
aprendo que ganhar é importante mas que
isso tem um custo e esse custo pode ser
alto demais a jogar
o experimento cidadania como andré
chegou na minha oficina de jogos no sesc
e ao longo de um mês ele roubava
sistematicamente ele chegava pra mim um
dia e falou assim potinho roubar o jogo
não tem graça legal é roubado
jogo limpo ele parou de roubar eu nunca
mais esqueci isso a necessidade que vem
a responsabilidade honestidade que vem
da empatia empatia e da oportunidade de
olhar pelos olhos dos outros de ver o
que o outro ver e sentir o que o outro
sente essa altura você já deve ter
percebido como falar tudo que eu faço o
jogo vale pra minha vida e tudo que eu
faço na vida eu posso ver sob a
perspectiva do jogo tão importante
quanto saber o jogo que você joga é
saber montar de jogo quando você sabe
que não pode mais ganhar
e aí um jogo é uma seqüência de escolhas
interessantes
o seu jogo vai determinar quais são as
escolhas
quais são os desafios e quais são os
aprendizados que você vai tirar disso
tudo e aí do outro lado e umg nos alerta
até que você se torna consciente do seu
inconsciente
você vai chamar isso de destino ele vai
governar sua vida
e aí nós temos a oportunidade de parar
de ser um peão
o tabuleiro do destino e começar a ser o
jogador do seu jogo vai
eu só dei brigava
[Aplausos]